are you drinking during class no
lemonade
and i just screamed what did i just do
this
is my online college horror story so
this was
my business class and fall semester and
this class is infamous for just being
miserable
so i sign up i take the class and it's
four to five hours of reading every
night
and it's on stupid stuff one day we were
doing a leadership activity during class
and the thing is about these leadership
activities when they put you in breakout
rooms we immediately bond with each
other over
how much we and this day
i was particularly not in the mood to
deal with anything related to this class
i was in a breakout room but i didn't
even have the breakout room open
i had amazon open and i remember i was
shopping for earrings i was shopping for
hoops actually
and i was just talking and i was like
yeah like yesterday's reading
even more stupid than ever why did that
thing take like six hours
these breakout remembers they're like
yeah you know like this is stupid
we shouldn't have to be doing that and
the entire breakout room is talking the
entire breakout room is agreeing with me
and i'm happily scrolling through amazon
my brain is somewhere else and i proceed
to say
like this class is such a show the
professor is such a
and suddenly no one in the breakout room
is agreeing with me and i was like wait
like what happened like did i say did i
go too far
and i remember the horror like oh my
gosh i'm feeling the horror again
and i opened up zoom and i see my
professor she's a muted herself
and she's turned her camera off and she
has silently popped into her breakout
room and i was like oh
my heart is racing i can't believe every
living this
what did she hear how long how long has
she been i didn't know how long she had
been there for i don't know what she's
heard i just switched right back to the
topic of the leadership activity which i
think was like teamwork or
something something i don't know i never
really paid attention and then she
leaves she leaves silently she doesn't
say anything so we just finished up our
activity
right and we popped back into the main
room and in my head i was like okay so
i'm going to fail this class it's fine
that's okay
and we pop back into the main room and
now my professor starts playing back
recordings of each breakout room she
goes one by one i think we're like group
six
and she's playing back our discussions
to show us how teamwork happens
right which is so like we all know how
it happens again why this class is
stupid when she gets to group six
she clicks play and i realize she's
recorded
everything i was saying and she plays it
and she lets like a solid
20 seconds go by just me saying like
these readings are stupid
like there's no organization waits for
it to play and then she fast forwards it
and plays our discussion about the topic
and she's like oh decent discussion you
guys got going there the biggest mistake
i've ever made in my life
i just closed my computer i went into my
closet and i just
screamed like like a shriek what did i
just do
i actually worked even harder after that
because i felt like i had to redeem
myself in a way
and i ended up getting a 91 and i did
really well in the course you want one
takeaway
you're not as screwed as you think you
are my room
is right behind our living room so the
tv is actually right next to
my wall and every single time my dad
turns it on every single
wavelength there is vibrates through my
wall especially once it's like in the
evening
i don't know about your parents but my
vietnamese parents
loves their karaoke they will bring it
into their bedroom if they can
during one of my quizzes my dad actually
turned on the karaoke
and started singing and i vividly
remember
telling the entire family like guys i
have something important
at 5 pm please no noise that totally
left their mind so
my dad was just seeing his heart out one
of my friends
in my class also messaged me dude is
your dad okay like he's really
passionately singing right now and i was
like
yes yes he's just living out his life
right now don't worry about
it and so another incident that also
involves my lovely father
was also during my public speaking class
i don't know why it just has to be that
hour of the day
i was pretty much a city in class
thankfully we weren't doing any
discussion or anything at this time it
was just my professor lecturing
and my dad during the quarantine he kind
of picked up making cocktails and drinks
and so
he kind of mastered making mojito that
day and
i was sitting in class you know on my
zoom and he walks in
with a glass of mojito and i just like
see him in the corner of my eye and i
was like hi dad
i'm in class and he was like yeah but
like i made this
really good mojito like finally i got it
down do you want to try it and i was
like
uh yeah sure like in a bit i'm in class
right now and he literally walks
over has a glass in his hand and he
literally just like weighs it by the
camera
and i was like okay father like all
right and then he like puts it right
under my mouth and had this draw
right through my mouth and i was just
like okay cool my friends a few of them
did notice it and they like
messaged me privately in the zoom
message and they were like dude
are you drinking during class and i was
like no
that was no lemonade like what are you
talking about
what are you talking about we all have
that one class where we dread going to
for this class i just felt like i needed
coffee i'm going to take the risk and
make my way to this coffee shop called
tierramia we order a coffee
we're having a good time the moment we
were on the freeway i realized that i
was kind of cutting it short there was a
lot of traffic
i'm rushing back home i'm like speeding
you know just trying to make it to class
because
this professor he will mark you absent
and you will get
points taken off i arrive home i set up
my computer i make sure wi-fi is good
it was like 6 59 i have like a minute
left he allows me in
he's taking roll already he writes my
name down real good
there's 35 students there for some
reason he always manages to pick on me
like good thing i do my homework i start
losing
wi-fi sometimes you have to leave the
class to be able to connect against your
wi-fi the moment i logged back in
that's when things like just took a turn
for the worse my professor right away
calls on me and he's like stephanie
what's the answer to this problem i've
been gone for 10 minutes so i don't even
know what problem he's talking about i
mute myself and i'm like professor
everyone pretended that he's like okay
stephanie well don't worry we'll wait
until you finally
are able to do the problem we're not
going anywhere we'll be here until like
11 if we have to
and it's like 8 o'clock at night and
class finishes at 9 45
that's when a student decided to message
me he was like oh stephanie this is the
problem by the way
this is how you do the problem i was
finally able to give him the answer and
i feel like he was surprised to be
honest the lesson i learned from this
story was that i need good wi-fi
because at the end of the day your
professors don't care
[Applause]
you